riesige waldbrände in kalifornien 14.000
feuerwehrleute kämpfen rund um die uhr
gegen die flammen wenn es sieben
menschen sind bislang ums leben gekommen
der kalifornische gouverneur news
spricht von historischen bränden laut
wwf expertin susanne winter sind die
riesigen feuer natürlichen ursprungs und
werden oftmals durch blitze und extreme
winter ausgelöst dazu sind starke
regenfälle ausgeblieben
normalerweise sind die wälder an die
klimatischen bedingungen angepasst weil
aber durch den klimawandel es immer
häufiger brennt und die bäume
austrocknen würde das problem für die
kalifornischen wälder immer größer viele
tiere sterben dabei weil sie meistens
nicht flüchten können entweder durch die
flammen oder die besiedlung der menschen
ob und wann die brände unter kontrolle
gebracht werden könnten ist unklar
die feuerwehr warnt es gibt zu wenige
feuerwehrleute und nicht genug
ausrüstung und so viele großbrände
gleichzeitig bewältigen zu können und
herbert bauernebel ist für uns in der
katastrophenregion in nordkalifornien du
begleitet die feuerwehrleute bei ihrer
schwierigen bei ihrer gefährlichen
arbeit herbert 14.000 feuerwehrleute
kämpfen gegen die flammen
man möchte meinen dass eine nation wie
die usa
feuer in den griff bekommt warum geraten
die immer so außer kontrolle
der feuer sind teil des lebens in
kalifornien natürlich keine frage und
die feuerwehren hier sind ausgestattet
und mit großen bränden umgehen zu können
was allerdings passiert in den letzten
jahren ist einfach eine verringerung
dieser präzision es beginnt früher es
beginnt heftiger es dauert länger
die feuer sind größer die feuer sind
stärker und das führt natürlich dazu
dass die feuerwehrleute einfach zu
wenige leute haben manchmal wenn sie an
zu vielen fronten im einsatz sein müssen
was hier dazu kam ist mitte dieses
monats gab es einen trockenen
gewittersturm der hat 11.000
blitzschläge verursacht praktisch das
trockene land bombardiert mit blitzen
und hier sind 600 feuer gleichzeitig
ausgebrochen
hier im großraum san francisco und da
brannte natürlich der hut auch
bei der feuerwehr weil einfach keine
möglichkeit bestand nachzukommen mit den
ressourcen mit den männern mit den
brandbekämpfern und deshalb haben sich
diese vor so rasant ausgebreitet das ist
jetzt der beginn der brutsaison muss man
dazu sagen und bereits jetzt sind hier
rekordwerte zu verzeichnen es ist mehr
mehr fläche abgebrannt als die als die
größe des grand canyon herbert und dann
kommt zu dieser brandkatastrophe noch
plünderung hinzu tja das ist eine
besonders traurige entwicklung natürlich
ein sheriff hat das als das tiefste vom
tiefsten bezeichnet und so die polizei
hat jetzt darauf reagiert aber einer
dieser straßensperren an der ich stehe
sieht man auch einen polizeiwagen hier
wird kontrolliert wer hier in die
evakuierungszone vorbringen kann und
jeder der hier keinen grund vorweisen
kann warum er sich aufhält in den
evakuierungszonen wird fest genau wenn
es wurde auch bekannt dass hier die geld
die geldbörse eines feuerwehrmannes
gestohlen wurde seine kreditkarten das
ganze konto leer geräumt wurde wirklich
eine entsetzliche entwicklung angesichts
des leids der bewohner die ihre häuser
verlieren und dann auch einige bewohner
die bestohlen werden von plünderern die
eben die kunst der stunde hier nutzen
und dann wird sich corona auch noch
negativ auf die brandbekämpfung aus denn
gefangene können nicht eingesetzt werden
gegen die flamme clowns dass wegen der
krone virus krise besonders hier in
kalifornien wurden viele häftlinge
freigelassen vorzeitig aus dem gefängnis
es handelt sich hier um straftäter die
keine besonderen gewaltverbrechen zu
verübt haben und deshalb keine
schwerverbrecher sind genau diese leute
aber helfen jedes jahr in kalifornien
breite bei der brandbekämpfung sind die
verlässlichsten helfer der feuerwehr und
genau diese leute wurden eben vorzeitig
entlassen aus der haftung die fehlen
jetzt an den brand fronten